package will be so cool
what's up everyone a happy sunday we
haven't had a male time in a while I've
got a bunch of packages and we're
excited to try to open them up together
and nobody is going to stop us trust me
it's really just hated playing Halloween
tricks so he's got a bunch of stock to
open up we have not won since we moved
into our condo and I think the first we
should do is from our real estate agent
Mark dullahan he gave this to us we
moved in tank in June yeah chance it's
been a while sorry mark sorry mark so
we're going to open this up and see what
it gave us okay go open will be the car
while he opens it up congrats on the
purchase he knew how this poem goes home
it was a pleasure working with you call
me if your fridges have to have or need
anything real estate advice see around
mark last time we had we lived in this
place our freezer was leaking and mark
see Miss help us fix it above and beyond
service and his clients smart olin and
we left mark we do love mark so what is
this a speaker looks like a speech is a
speaker we can now a blast salsa music
and get in trouble with the neighbors
with our new speaker thank you Mark okay
package will be so cool let's do this
big one here if you guys want to send us
anything for the next mail time we'll
put the address in the description so
you can find this vacuum robot vacuum by
Bobby this was actually a former student
at tron dance salsa now runs this
company that sells robotic vacuums I
think this is also the Mach 1 right
robotic vacuum cleaner and Bob Bobby by
Bob sleep I like the modern design too
that we were using a Roomba but Nina's
hair is destroyed okay destroy broke the
brushes fills up the container so I'm
excited to give this one a shot and see
if it can handle it's got some like
rugged things on the side there look at
the side there it says Go juice and
waffle if it can handle Lina hair then
it's ready for the army I'm excited
thank you ollie super pumped to check
this out ok next one we got oh this is
ed oh this is ed I hate the cold com
perfect timing this is a i hain't warmer
in the battery backup charger and has a
company feeling that it is a friend
local Toronto entrepreneur and he gave
us two of these Nina had the pink when I
had the gray one in the pink one we had
to move it so Nina then took my grave
one and I've never be able to see it
again because every time she goes toe
c'mon hunting she runs at a battery and
uses my battery charger so now we've got
a new one battery saver I love it Thank
You ed muscles muscles bra muscles this
is the hoodie from who oh this is peter
boom this is a become a legendary young
ambition I didn't interview with Peter
on my youtube channel and he was wearing
this hoodie and I said you gotta send
you one of those bro so this is it got a
little buddy I got used to the fish
become legendary all right let's check
out they didn't even Peter do it's good
okay Nina Wow what'd you guys get like
project good life project this is from
Jonathan fields at the top there it says
advanced reading copy October 2016 good
luck project Jonathan has an awesome
YouTube channel about how to live a good
life does a bunch of interviews with
people and so he's launching a book I'm
super excited to uh the dive in the
field oh we're running out to Evan
here's the gallon for how to live the
good life it's out October 18th hope you
enjoy and looking forward to connecting
with gratitude Jonathan I love it Thank
You Jonathan gonna check it out feature
of a channel probably superpump book oh
here six months of six figures oh and a
CD what's on here miss me cool so this
is Peter it's the same this is the same
guy I got the hoodie from that's his
book six months and six figures cool and
thank you for the book to pump to
rethread okay next crap feels like
another book take me wide open this Oh
another book oh look at that that's
different million-dollar Glock let's
check it out please find it closed a
bound proof of the million-dollar log on
behalf of the Tasha we hope you enjoy
all the best rip back that from little
brown get a lot of books i'll let this I
like this thing here did a lot of books
look at all this alright next out this
feels like another book to this is like
book day okay what do we got this is
from Dupree Miller what made me who I am
during swing cool this so there you go
what made me who I am Bernie was on the
channel as well I didn't hang out with
him super interesting guy started one of
the largest and most respected speaking
agencies in America booking speakers out
on on different gigs and so this is his
new book so I'm excited to read it not
for sale advanced uncorrect
it's all be like all the all the
advanced versions of what we're doing so
Thank You Bernie looking forward to
reading that ha I got it I got a five
times we don't because people like
sending me books Oh God okies two books
and a card so Keith Keith Washoe Keith
wrote this book the heart of success
where he interviewed a bunch of people
executives in Silicon Valley
understanding what led to their success
oh you even for Sandra that's awesome
and we gonna hang up to and super cool
guy and I just set it to dive into the
book there's a interesting interview
tues to check that out and what have you
right thank you look at that dear Emma
thank you for the opportunity part of
your show and share the book the hard
success I'm a big fan of all you do in
order to be able to join you for a show
thank you for looking thank you and I
look forward to supporting best regards
Keith love it I'm gonna have to do these
two for my book I'm really worried about
my handwriting guys I'm really worried
about my handwriting okay people have
put this is solid like I am feeling opus
in your list maybe you're gonna have to
write it I'll say it and you write it
and then I'll sign it they're gonna
think I really girly handwriting I don't
know we'll see we'll have to figure that
out thank you Keith I love it last like
we've got these two things I wonder
what's in here open it up mister Wow we
actually ordered this for hidden he's
been looking for you open this up Oh
Pokemon stickers wall steep to decorate
his room
Snorlax oh yeah and all the Leaning
hidden do on the weekends let's go to
Pokemon hunting so thank you guys so
much for watching thank you for all the
awesome gifts looking forward to digging
into them have an amazing rest of the
weekend if you want to send me anything
the address is below so you get featured
on the next mail time and get around to
it thank you guys so much for watching
get you to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon we'll see
you soon